here now with reaction Fox News
contributors kellyanne Conway Ari
Fleischer okay I'm glad about that part
that Hunter has to do that kellyanne let
me start with you
and I'd really like to know you know
when you look at this in total and you
look at the aggressive prosecution of
Donald Trump who you work for for all
those years and you look at the the
absolute the opposite treatment no
prosecutor would prosecute subpoenaed
emails deleted 33 000 no problem a dirty
dossier four locations top secret
classified information for Joe Biden no
raids no charges nothing
um what is it what is what should the
average American especially a
conservative think about Law and Order
and Justice in this country
that there is special treatment I
thought would the Delaware judge
Christopher Burke did today Sean was
masterful finally for the first time in
years if not decades Hunter Biden and
his family are being told no special
treatment for you here's a guy hunter
Biden who we're told lives at the White
House has time to fly to Arkansas in a
private jet his friend's jet to deny
paternity and compensation and
Birthright and his and the family name
to his daughter but has no time has no
time to go to Delaware where he is far
too often along with his father
to go and appear in front of court so
this is I think this is the wall
starting to break a little bit for
Hunter Biden people have had enough this
gun charge is serious other people have
been prosecuted and punished for it and
he'll have to under oath admit also that
he lied about using and being addicted
to narcotics as part of that as part of
that same time period also he at the
time was involved in a relationship with
his deceased brother's widow Hallie who
it is also alleged through one of
Hunter's guns into a bin a container
behind the market so all this stuff that
the White House denies as just picking
on poor Hunter the president is proud of
his son leave him alone already that's
all going to be under oath now and we're
going to be able to see that and it's
finally time for this because the
conservatives and not just conservatives
look Donald Trump is beating Joe Biden
in most polls by double digits among
Independents Sean and Ari and the reason
is because of what you just laid out
Sean people are so tired of this whole
treatment
based on who you are these Independents
don't trust government to begin with but
I think we're start we're finally
starting to see and you know what not a
lot of Democrats seem to be they seem to
be supporting Biden as a nominee but
they don't seem to be defending his son
and him in this regard so I think if the
bidens are hung out they'll you know
they'll they'll turn around and find
somebody else to be on the ticket what
about the Joe part Ari Fleischer lies
repeatedly as a candidate as a president
about never speaking to to Hunter his
brother or anybody for that matter then
we find all these meetings that take
place in the in the white house with his
you know with Hunter's Partners here in
America then we have all the phone calls
that Devin Archer talked about with
Hunter and his farm business partners
then you have the meetings with like the
Russian oligarch and others at Cafe
Milano a Russian oligarch uh what did
Hunter do why this why the suspicious
activity reports 170 why the shell
corporations how did nine Biden family
members get paid what did Hunter do when
he admits he had no experience in a she
was an addict at the time what did the
grandchildren that Comer says got paid
what did they do for their money uh any
of this make sense to you
oh sure it makes sense that's what you
do if you're the president's son and
your last name is Biden no other
president's son has done this well maybe
he can adopt me I'll be pretty rich
[Applause]
you're better than a body you don't want
that uh
was a joke yeah but listen he here's the
here's the problem that I have with all
of this
Hunter Biden said that his father I'm
sorry it was a hunter who said it the
people making the accusations against
Hunter Biden are who there's not Jim
Jordan it's not Republicans it's
Hunter's business partners it's the
people who he worked with who know the
facts who are on the inside these aren't
partisan Republicans they're
eyewitnesses and what did they say they
testified under oath that Joe Biden 20
times got on the phone to help his son
with business deals
that in and of itself is an act of
corruption by the then Vice President of
the United States
I cannot imagine any other Congressman
senators or the president I ever worked
for getting on the phone to influence
business deals for their children
because they're sitting members of
Congress they know it's unethical it's
wrong but Joe Biden did it anyway and he
did it because he thought he'd be
protected he thought the Press wouldn't
come after him and finally they are
because the facts in this case are so
bad for Hunter but there's still those
other charges that we hope to see if
that other shoe drops now beyond the gun
charge that does get close to the White
House because it involves his father's
behavior
and Nancy mace and James Comer both said
to me this week they think the Biden's
alone they're going to get north of 50
million dollars when it's all said just
the bidens that they can track now maybe
more thank you both hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else